Joanne, it's really, really exciting to actually look at my paternal
line and see sort of how far back in time and, and
geography we can go with this. But, if you don't have a
Y chromosome then how could you ever look at your paternal lineage?
>> Yeah. And many women are interested in exactly that same thing.
Even though we don't have Y chromosomes. So, but there is a way
to trace your paternal line even if you don't have a y
chromosome. And that is to find someone who has your father's y chromosome.
my father passed away years ago so he
wasn't available for testing. but my uncle kindly
agreed to get tested and so I was able to learn about my paternal line through
him. And other possibilities if I had had
a brother. If my paternal grandfather had been
alive. So there are a number of relatives
who can help a woman trace her paternal line.
>> Okay, Matt. So, we see here that you
and your dad have a, a paternal lineage called I1.
>> Mm hm.
>> actually, I1 star. And we see, from the map, that it's very,
very frequent in Northern Europe, particularly in
Scandinavia. I don't know if you were
aware of any Scandinavian ancestry on your
dad's side. But that's, this is suggesting
that if you go far enough back on your dad's side. you might find
that you have an ancestor who's, lives in Scandinavia.
>> Now this fits with the autosomal ancestry pattern that we saw
for me, right, where it said I had a strong Northern European descent.
>> That's right. Yes, yes, yes. So this
is just. Reinforcing that information that we see.
>> I see, and it says that over here
that age is 28,000 years. What does that mean exactly?
>> So this lineage like all the the haplogroups are
defined by a particular mutation that happened,
you know, a long time ago. And in
this case, 28,000 years ago a mutation
happened on the y chromosome. And it's the
defining, and then everybody who inherited that particular y chromosone also
inherited that mutation. And so, the last 28,000 years men
and their sons have carried that particular mutation and you
are part of kind of that clan.
>> I see.
>> Of, of males with this particular lineage.
>> So this means that, in this region here.
Somewhere in this region is where that mutation happened.
>> It's, well.
>> About 28,000 years ago?
>> We don't know for sure where it happened.
But because it's most frequent in this general region now.
>> I see.
>> We, We speculate that it was probably in that,
in that general area. You know, very far North in Europe.
>> Now,
let's take a look, at actually. Let's go back to Roy.
>> Yes. King.
>> Roy King and his father, Roy King, Sr, both have a lineage that is
fairly common in in Jewish men. and that
fits with Roy's understanding that his father's father was Jewish. So,
we're really seeing his grandfather right there in the DNA
of the y chromosome. So to go a little deeper let's click on
the history tab and move away from the map. And this is an
overall, you know, story about the, the history of this lineage J2.
and and it mentions the, the
branches of this J2 haplogroup spreading with the Jewish diaspora from
the Middle East across Europe. so this is just what is, and
this, all this information comes from studies of people who currently carry the
J2 lineage around the world. And so many scientists have conducted studies
and they publish papers and then this story is drawn from those publications.